[Musique]
depuis quelques jours près de 22
millions de français constatent une
baisse de leur taxe d'habitation sur
leur avis d'imposition conséquences de
la suppression progressive de la taxe
d'habitation prévu pour 80% des français
est engagé depuis l'an dernier
bienvenue dans ce set 8 débat à
l'université des mairies des yvelines
sur la taxe d'habitation avec deux
invités
le sénateur la république en marche des
yvelines martin lévriers bonjour c'est
votre accueil et le maire divers droite
de l'étang la vie de jean yves bourg
bonjour bonjour alors le batteur salué
le processus de suppression de la taxe
d'habitation va se faire en trois temps
donc il a été engagé en 2018 avec une
baisse de 30 % de la taxe d'habitation
le dégrèvement se poursuit dans le
projet de loi de finances 2010 9
actuellement en discussion au parlement
à hauteur de 65 % avant d'atteindre 100
% en 2020 et donc la suppression
définitive de cette taxe je le rappelle
pour 80% des français
est ce qu'elle est nécessaire cette
réforme martin lee briers elle est
nécessaire et indispensable pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison et
on l'a dit répété mais c'est important
quand même c'est de rappeler que la taxe
d'habitation n'a pas évolué depuis les
années 70 et elle est devenue totalement
inégalitaire en fonction du lieu où vous
habitez un exemple à sarcelles pour un
appartement identique à paris vous payez
cinq fois plus cher
a priori les habitants de paris sont
plus aisé que les habitants de sarcelles
donc y avait vraiment une
une taxe est un impôt totalement injuste
et un réformable puisque tous les
gouvernements s'y sont essayés et tous
ont abandonné la chose donc quitte à
faire quelque chose il était intelligent
dans un premier temps de dire puisque le
système ne fonctionne pas qu'à son le et
reconstruisons ensemble c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que l'on
reproche à la france d'avoir beaucoup
trop d'impôts mais voilà un gouvernement
qui dès le départ s'engagent à baisser
les impôts à hauteur de plus de 7
milliards
et qui le fait et qui permet grâce à ça
de redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français
en particulier les moins aisés oui mais
c'est un impôt supprimer qui est quand
même la principale ressource fiscale des
communes et là je me tourne vers vous
j'ai un humour en tant que maire des
temps la ville
je pense que vous êtes sceptique par
rapport à cette heure réforme bien alors
fallait-il supprimer la taxe
d'habitation comme vous le dites mon
cher sénateur
on trouvera des points de convergence
sur la nécessité de faire évoluer la
taxe d'habitation mais une réponse nette
d'entrée non il ne fallait pas supprimer
la taxe d'habitation
il est vrai que lorsque la la promesse
de campagne du président de la
république qui s'est fait élire aussi
grâce il faut bien le dire à une
proposition de réduction forte du
prélèvement fiscal ça avait du sens
parce que nous savons tous que la taxe
d'habitation et vous l'avez dit monsieur
le sénateur vieillit c'est pas bien mais
si elle ne vieillit c'est pas bien
c'était bien parce que les politiques
depuis une quarantaine d'années n'ont
pas eu tout à fait le courage pour faire
évoluer ses taxes d'habitation qu'est ce
que la taxe d'habitation c'est un impôt
payé par tous occupants de logements
meublés au 1er janvier de l'année de
chacune des communes de france
c'est le lien direct entre des services
publics rendus à une population et le
coude de ses services rendus
c'est l'expression même d'une
citoyenneté total et à partir du moment
où vous supprimez ce lien pour la
plupart de tous les contribuables
tous ceux qui ont des revenus inférieurs
un certain seuil comme vous le savez ce
lien n'existe plus et c'est dangereux
pourquoi parce que premièrement il va
bien falloir que quelqu'un paye et il va
y avoir un transfert au niveau de l'état
et on peut dire que la taxe d'habitation
en fête et du tax nationalisées et
deuxièmement à partir du moment où dans
nos communes
nous n'allons plus pouvoir voter un
produit fiscal avec le levier fiscal
symbole d'une certaine indépendance et
d'une autonomie de nos collectivités
locales
les contribuables certain en tout cas
vont considérer que tout est gratuit
ils ne vont pas payer les services dans
les communes à travers l'intégration ya
même un effet pervers
on peut même imaginer que ça ira dans le
sens d'un accroissement de la dépense
publique parce qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez l'impression que tout compte
fait les services que l'on vous rend non
pas de coups puisqu'on vous demande pas
l'impôt correspondant
on risque d'avoir un dérapage accélérée
de la dépense publique alors que hello
je vous rejoins il est vrai qu'il
fallait faire évoluer cette taxe il
fallait remettre en cause la base
fiscale
il fallait donner des éléments nouveaux
qui permettait une meilleure comparaison
en lien avec l'effort fiscal qui est
demandé à chacun des citoyens
martin lévriers peut être pour répondre
sur cette déconnexion finalement de
l'imposition et cette nationalisation de
la position par deux éléments d'abord
dire il aurait fallu la transformer
travailler les bases
je vous rappelle que tous les
gouvernements s'y sont essayés est
vraiment essayé le dernier gouvernement
hollande a vraiment essayé je les subis
puisque j'étais salarié avant j'ai ruiné
j'ai dû reculer tout et m² à travailler
infernale qui n'a servi à rien qui a
fait travailler des fonctionnaires qui
avaient travaillé dans ce domaine privé
tout le monde et qui n'a donné aucun
résultat donc le sujet était trop grave
et on n'y arrivait plus j'aime bien sûr
la déconnexion avec mary et citoyens et
habitants de la ville
je pourrais en partie partagé ce que
vous dites sauf que il ya déjà
énormément de personnes qui sont
exonérés de la taxe d'habitation ces
personnes-là actuellement 20 % 20 %
c'est pas rien qui sont exonérés de la
taxe d'habitation
rien de nouveau c'est pas pourtant c'est
pas pour autant qu'ils sont hors la
ville même chose si on reprend l'impôt
sur le revenu énormément de français ne
sont pas imposables ne sont pas imposées
pour autant ils sont tout autant
français que les autres et se sentent
autant appliquer c'est un problème de
civisme j'allais dire mais si le civisme
ne passe que par l'argent que je verse
jeu devient un consommateur et moi je ne
suis pas sûr que cette approche soit la
meilleure elle existe c'est un sujet
c'est important que les les citoyens
l'est de la ville sache combien ça
coûtera ça c'est plus de la pédagogie de
budget et des analyses budgétaires et de
suite budget qu'on doit apprendre à nos
concitoyens plus kobe attendant payer un
impôt qui a un effet répressif ou alors
juste pour prendre un exemple dans votre
commune par exemple budget 2018 c'est
6,5 millions d'euros dont 2,3 millions
d'euros produit de la taxe d'habitation
c'était dans votre budget primitif et on
a fait le calcul c'est 35 % de vos
recettes totales quelle conséquence
finalement il ya suite à cette
suppression
mais cher monsieur dans ma commune de
l'étang la ville
25% des citoyens des contribuables des
redevables de la taxe d'habitation sont
touchés par la réforme 25% ce qui veut
dire que 75% continueront de par leur
lait leur revenu imposable continueront
à payer la taxe d'habitation 75%
vous avez dans d'autres communes
monsieur d'autres communes de france et
en région ile de france où 80 % des
citoyens sont impactés par la réforme
voilà encore là une source d'inéquité
d'inégalité entre les communes c'est
tout à fait évident nous le levier
fiscal va rester assez dynamique dans
d'autres communes il va de toute façon
disparaître et monsieur le sénateur a
évoqué quelque chose d'intéressant
puisque vous avez parlé de la peau sur
leur venue pour dire que c'est pas parce
que la moitié des français ne le payent
pas que de toute façon ceux qui ne
payent pas perdraient leur citoyenneté
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord c'est
une évidence mais c'est un bon exemple
l'impôt sur revenu aussi c'est pas le
sujet mais la fiscalité c'est un tout
doit aussi mérite aussi une belle
réforme à partir du moment où vous avez
un impôt qui ne paient que par une seule
une partie une faible partie des
citoyens
c'est mauvais c'est mauvais pour les
dépenses publiques
c'est mauvais pour la république moi je
rêve d'un pot large avec des taux
faibles où tout le monde est concerné ou
là il y a une démarche beaucoup plus
équitable et pour les communes on se
retrouverait bien plus confortablement
eux installés c'est un lévrier peut-être
voulu répondre
alors c'est personnellement un point
d'accord que j'avais vous monsieur le
maire je pense que sur le moyen terme
long terme moyen terme il va bien
falloir un jour se poser cette question
quand il ya autant de personnes qui ne
paient pas d'impôts est ce ça donc c'est
un vrai sujet ça c'est un autre débat
voilà c'est pour acheter le jeu je
m'arrête tout de suite je reviens sur le
nombre de personnes dans votre commune
et dans d'autres communes qui se sont
exonérés de la taxe d'habitation
je vous rappelle quand même que dans
trois ans 100 %
des personnes 100 % des personnes ça a
été redit seront exonérés ses peintures
c'est certain dans le sens où le conseil
constitutionnel nous invitait fortement
à le faire c'est certain dans le sens où
je reprends je ne pense pas mais moi je
les dis paris justement on prend un pari
ou pourquoi pas à 100% je suis prêt avec
jupe verte et 26 milliards ont des
trouvera pas je suis prêt à parier avec
vous et là on se retrouve aux
universités des maires de l'année
prochaine au thé et on verra alors ils
ont deux heures le sais moi deux ans je
jouais trop détailler ce jeu continue
vous parliez du budget de la mairie de
l'est dans la vie mais d'autres mairies
aussi l'impact budgétaire nuls l'état
s'est engagé à rendre à rembourser et
c'est déjà prévu vous l'avez vu dans le
dans le collectif budgétaire qui est en
cours donc de ce côté là il ya c'est un
non sujet mais pour moi c'est un non
sujet il n'est pas question que les
maires de communes soient privés d'une
recette aussi importante et aussi
dynamique ce qui est important c'est de
la rendre encore plus dynamique et avec
l'ensemble des collectivités si on y
travaille et je parce que quand vous
parlez de remboursement il ne s'agit pas
d'exonérer les citoyens il s'agit de les
graver sur la base d'une assiette qui
évoluent tous les ans l'état s'engage à
compenser sur la base de l'assiette
réévalué affecté du taux de l'impôt de
2017 à nous rembourser ce manque à
gagner qui représente un dégrèvement
pour les citoyens imaginez dans nos
communes
nous modifions nos politique
d'abattement nous modifions nos taux
d'imposition
le citoyen qui aujourd'hui crois que lui
il va continuer à être exonérées th il
ne le sera plus il paiera peut-être à la
marge mais toute modification de
l'assiette par modification des
abattements toute modification du
produit par vote d'un taux nouveau va
donner naissance à un autre impôt th qui
lui ne sera pas des grèves et un sachet
le premier rang est alors j'imagine et
certains sénateurs moi je vous de cette
information
je la tiens de gens très sûrs d'eux
vous verrez monsieur le sénateur on ne
pourra pas aller à l'ego dégrèvement de
100%
un citoyen mais c'est le berceau juste
pour embrasser à bien et on boit le
champagne avec vous dans deux ans gardez
pas revenir sur les autos géré par les
mairies c'est tout à fait vrai je
reviens sur le débat oui non mais c'est
juste pour revenir sur le débat pour
pour progresser allons plus loin dans la
réflexion parce que le gouvernement
quand même pour accompagner cette
suppression prévoit une refonte totale
de la fiscalité locale
une loi qui sera présenté en ce sens
l'un des prochaines premier semestre
2010 9 à partir d'un rapport qui a été
rendu au premier ministre en mai dernier
alors alors il ya quelques lignes déjà
qu'ils sont uniques et leurs rapports
excusez moi y ait eu un pré rapport fait
par par monsieur bourg et mon collègue
alain richard monsieur burbure pas
dangereuse et moi et alain richard
ooyala richard qui ont proposé un pré
rapport qui a été transmis à
l'association des maires de france et à
d'autres pour travailler l'objectif
depuis le début c'est de dire c'est un
pot et supprimer cet impôt doit revenir
est supprimé pour le pour le pour les
citoyens il n'est pas supprimée pour les
mairies ni pour les collectivités donc
il faut trouver effectivement une
nouvelle approche et une nouvelle
dynamique cette nouvelle dynamique
elle ne peut pas être fait
par l'état et seulement par l'état
puisque les plus intelligents dans
l'histoire c'est ceux qui la vivent
alors c'est juste trois minutes et
excusez moi le parlons et vous ne parlez
pas de réforme fiscale
ce n'est pas une réforme une réforme
fiscale c'est un aménagement sur wii
allez moi j'oserais dire c'est un
bricolage
comment voulez-vous parler de réformes
de refonte de la fiscalité
quand il ne s'agit que de prendre la
taxe foncière propriétés bâties des
départements la confia l'interco allait
prendre un bout de ses jets pour
financer les dépenses sociales des
départements c'est vous allez proposer
ne m'attendais pas moi à les pendre ou
tva pour ses projets sinistre
d'accession me permettre monsieur le
sénateur et je pense que nous serons
d'accord c'est pas ça une réforme
il fallait reprendre le travail à la
base c'est pas une redistribution de
situation actuelle alors excusez moi il
faut il faut reprendre la genèse et se
rappeler que c'est une négociation pour
réformer la taxe d'habitation ça n'est
pas une réforme globale de la fiscalité
locale on est bien d'accord parce que ça
demandera plus de temps et ça doit être
fait ça doit être fait ensemble
le problème que nous avons aujourd'hui
vous le savez bien c'est que l'état veut
négocier veut faire participer les
collectivités qui freinent des quatre
fers
alors qu'elle pourrait prendre la main
complètement prendre le sujet en main et
trouver des solutions dynamiques ou
demeurant les solutions proposées par ce
rapport ont été plutôt approuvé par
monsieur l'oniam par monsieur laignel
donc on en est là moi je
j'aimerais vraiment j'aimerais vraiment
que les maires prennent la main et 10 on
a des idées plus intelligente et je fais
ni qu'autrement à s'imaginer avec vous
la fiscalité mais moi je regarde des
conclusions du rapport richard bur je
regarde les conclusions du comité des
finances locales présidé par monsieur
daniel qui
très très bon boulot mais qu'est ce
qu'ils disent ils disent à la fin et
c'est la même conclusion
c'est assez c'est assez extraordinaire
il nous faut réformer les valeurs
locatives des locaux d'habitation
il annonce quelque chose une chose qui
est dit
qui est commentée depuis 40 ans alors
s'il faut une commission des rapporteurs
que les gens se réunissent pour enfoncer
dépens de metz a déjà les bras que ça et
vous le savez très bien
ces dernières si elle est là vous le
savez non les la transfert de la taxe
foncier on a beaucoup de maires du
travail
il ya une part de tva c'est quand même
très intéressant qui va être mise au
pied au panier et la tva vous le savez
c'est un impôt dynamique donc il va
faire qui va changer le regard des
vilains sur sénateur vous vous êtes en
marche
moi je suis en mouvement peut-être alors
on arrive au terme de ce débat peut-être
deux un élément de conclusions chacun en
moins de 30 secondes à l'est eh bien
écoutez il ne fallait pas supprimer la
taxe d'habitation mais il fallait un
courage politique pour la faire évoluer
la réformer et là où je vous rejoins
c'est que depuis une trentaine une
quarantaine d'années personne ait eu le
courage de véritablement prendre le
chantier à bras le corps monsieur le
sénateur ma conclusion je vous remercie
de ces quelques mots et en particulier
du courage parce que le courage je crois
que nous montrons que nous en avons
puisque effectivement nous faisons des
réformés pour les faire on avance vite
fort et intelligemment mais toujours et
en la volonté de travailler avec vous et
directement avec vous et c'est
aujourd'hui là où le bât blesse il
faudrait qu'on retrouve cette envie de
travailler ensemble vient des yvelines
monsieur le chêne absolument très bons
éléments de conclusion merci à tous les
débats ne détenus sur notre plateau
débattent des questions fiscales
monsieur merci à rester avec nous
l'édition spéciale sur télé 60,18 se
poursuit à l'université des mairies des
yvelines
[Musique]